I just really really think about how
these people are never going to be at my
funeral and it's just not going to
matter I think that my self-image hasn't
changed a ton I think I've just
increased self-acceptance did you know
that if you zoom out far enough you
can't see Earth and so a lot of my like
insecurities and a lot of the things
that I would spend a lot of mental time
chewing on of like what does this person
think of me what does that person think
of me that just vanished when I realized
that they're gonna die and in a thousand
years No One's Gonna remember either of
us it just gave me a lot of permission
to just like do me and I think that's
probably the biggest difference that's
happened I don't think it had anything
to do with money I think that's just
been like personal development but that
personal development might have helped
me create more money